pour vous conter ses initiales berger
piste et sur les autres derrière
idem si tu te débrouilles bien tu pour
aller à paris quelques mois je ne loue
lot
elle va passer faut d'abord ça suffit et
pourquoi ne reviendriez vous pas la
maison nous n'avons plus nourrissant au
nom toudic enfin quand même vous n'y
pensez pas mais vous vous croyez vous
aux gens des cas sinon bonjour madeleine
bonjour mademoiselle chatel on a vu
passer trois nourrices en un mois alors
attention mademoiselle bécassine là
c'est l'heure du biberon c'est
automatique vous payez pas de mine comme
ça mais là vous embauchez un quoi
[Musique]
ce soir à grand spectacle de
marionnettes internationale alors que
murray est un peu faible quand même
oh vous avez ri je vous ai vu un
monsieur rythme si stupide
[Musique]
fiché 1905 je vais tout sans rien sur la
presqu'île au fait mai 68 les
marionnettistes que moi je suis danseuse
étoile
vous êtes danseuse étoile non
[Musique]
monsieur rasta cros pas promis qu'il
reviendra
vous pouvez me placer madame la marquise
est urgent je reviens monsieur reste à
claques hausse madame d'ortiz un sac où
l'opa l'appareil
[Musique]